crucial moment in the last undecided
Senate race of course it's in Georgia
Senator Rafael Warnock is getting some
prominent help in trying to fend off a
challenge from Republican Herschel
Walker former president Barack Obama hit
the campaign Trail in Atlanta to make a
very forceful argument on warnock's
behalf Nicole Killian is in Georgia for
us where early turnout has been high
ahead of election day on Tuesday Nicole
President Obama had some zingers
yesterday
yeah that's right Gail and good morning
to you as you can see dozens of people
are already waiting in line on this last
day of early voting Georgia election
officials say more than a million people
have already cast their ballot bar
outpacing runoffs back in 2016 and 2018
and last night the former president
urged supporters to keep it up and not
get tired or complacent
Georgia helped me to do it one more time
hoping to maximize turnout ahead of this
closely contested run-up Senator Rafael
Warnock turned to a reliable source you
get a
buy one get one free deal
on elections this year former president
Barack Obama made his case for the
incumbent to add to the Democrats
majority 51 is better than 50 because it
means Reverend Warnock will keep
representing you in Washington
and he took another jab at warnock's
opponent Herschel Walker Mr Walker has
been talking about issues that are of
great importance to the people of
Georgia
like whether it's better to be a vampire
or a werewolf
this is a debate
that I must confess I once had myself
when I was seven
you can tell that they're getting
nervous because they got Obama here
again the GOP nominee held a competing
rally with South Carolina Senator
Lindsey Graham after casting his own
ballot I just voted can you see the
former football star also pushed
supporters to get to the polls as he
fights new allegations a former
girlfriend told The Daily Beast Walker
is unstable and records show he took a
tax break in Texas intended for primary
residences while running in Georgia from
Georgia born Georgia bred and when I die
be Georgia dead Herschel Walker will
probably go down as one of the worst
Republican candidates in in our party's
history outgoing Republican lieutenant
governor Jeff Duncan said he couldn't
bring himself to support Walker or
Warnock leaving his ballot empty this
week unfortunately didn't have anybody
that achieved that uh you know respect
out of me or my vote
back in the November general election
about 200 000 voters back Governor Brian
Kemp but didn't support Walker and so
that is a critical block for both
candidates as Warnock tries to pick them
off and Walker tries to win them back
the GOP Governor did throw his support
behind Walker campaigning with him
recently and cutting several ads Vlad
Nicole Killian for us Nicole thank you
very much